[Music]
supporters of west bengal's governing
trinimal congress party or tmc celebrate
victory in the capital kolkata
that's despite the election commission
banning all celebrations because of
india's high number of coronavirus cases
but supporters said they wanted to mark
mamtha banerjee's re-election
for a third term as chief minister
from our hearts we have good wishes for
energy and that is why we are
celebrating
we already knew that tmc will win
because the development has been done by
tmc
not anyone else earlier the left was in
power but they did nothing
175 million people were eligible to vote
in the states of west bengal assam
tamilnade kerala and puducherry
politicians including prime minister
narendra modi have been criticized for
holding
large election rallies during a second
wave of coronavirus
the world health organization said such
gatherings are one of the reasons for
india's surgeon cases
four candidates died in west bengal
after contracting covet 19.
political analysts say the government
focused on winning elections
instead of preparing for the latest
surge the central government
was wholly unprepared for it in february
on february 21st they held a meeting of
their national executive i covered the
bjp so i know
they passed a political resolution the
bjp uh
saying claiming that the prime minister
narendra modi has defeated corona
and there were all these fantastical
claims about how indian immunity
is so strong and we are not like the the
the best who are
who are vulnerable to to pandemics and
so on
india is now relying on international
aid as its hospitals are struggling with
shortages of
beds oxygen equipment and medicines
prime minister narendra modi held a
meeting with health experts about the
shortages not just of beds and supplies
but also
healthcare workers that says reports
emerge from rural areas of people dying
as life-saving equipment including
ventilators are lying unused
without the doctors who have the
expertise
to use them elizabeth purana al jazeera
new delhi